[Música]
bienvenidos a en cinco minutos con entró
en vigencia en algunos países la primera
norma internacional para combatir la
violencia y el acoso laboral hacia la
mujer conocida como convenio 190 por eso
hablamos hoy con mariano él va es a ella
es la directora regional para las
américas y el caribe de naciones unidas
la saludamos y le preguntamos primero
sólo seis países del mundo han
ratificado el convenio entre ellos tres
de américa latina argentina ecuador y
uruguay en este este último es pionero
en qué consiste esta norma internacional
bueno buenos días y muchas gracias por
tenerme en eso le damos esta norma
internacional tiene muchas innovació
amigos la primera es reconocer que hay
acoso laboral es reconocer que la mujer
es víctima de ese acoso en el ámbito
laboral no solamente en el ámbito
laboral sino en el transporte hacia el
ámbito laboral y también en el
ciberespacio y hoy en día si el trabajo
desde la casa es tan importante es lo
importante específica que significa la
violencia y el acoso de pd2 y que se
ejerce a las personas por razón de su
puesto o de su gente y esto es
importante porque los países ahora que
entra en vigor tienen que implementarlo
a través de una ley y la ley normalmente
se hace de manera tripartita
trabajadores sindicatos el gobierno los
empleadores los perfectos privados
entonces esto va a llevar a un diálogo
nacional para ver
ataca de cerca je los que obviamente
creció a raíz de la pandemia porque no
nos olvidemos que la violencia contra la
mujer es una pandemia en la sombra que
está bien
mariano el en américa latina' el trabajo
doméstico supone entre el 10 5 y el 14
3% del empleo de las mujeres y más del
77% operan la informalidad porque es tan
importante que las naciones
latinoamericanas ratifiquen y legislen
en torno justamente a esta normativa
justamente porque los mayores abusos los
mayores acosos laborales se producen en
estas trabajadoras del hogar
trabajadoras que son fundamentales y que
han sido fundamentales durante la
pandemia y lamentablemente son ellas las
víctimas mayores de estos acosos además
de que no debería hacer un trabajo
informal tras ser regulado por el
convenio 189 que los países tienen que
tener una una legislación laboral formal
que las proteja por ende está esa
convención la va a proteger aún más así
que esperemos que esas trabajadoras y no
sólo las trabajadoras domésticas del
hogar pero ellas son las que sufren más
pero las trabajadoras rurales por
ejemplo este convenio no tiene espacio
físico es en lo rural es en lo urbano y
también en todos los sectores de la
economía el sector público sector
privado y todos los sectores de la
comunidad por eso es tan importante que
comiencen estos diálogos
que comience esta hoja de ruta que los
países tienen que hacer a raíz del marco
global de la comentan que es fundamental
las convenciones de la oit son
fundamentales para continuar con el
avance y las normas sociales laborales
que son fundamentales y mucho más ahora
que hay que confrontar
consulte con subir a través de el cob y
no sean sol y demos que en distintas las
trabajadoras que perdieron más sus
trabajos fueron las mujeres porque
estaban en los sectores más proyectadas
como la hostelería la restauración los
mercados y thomert por eso es tan
importante regular y que regulemos
tomando en cuenta que la violencia es
una realidad y que hay que erradicar lo
bueno y brevemente usted hablaba de los
empleos de las mujeres perdidos es
posible que sus empleos no se vuelvan a
recuperar o cuánto pueden tardar en
hacerlo
bueno es posible que nos sobra
recuperarnos olvidemos las avances
tecnológicos los avances que han
generado digamos la economía digital por
eso es tan importante la formación
laboral empezando por las mujeres por
eso estamos abogando por una canasta
básica digital no nos olvidemos que hay
40 por ciento de mujeres que no acceden
a la tecnología por eso con la coop
alcohol agüita estamos abogando
justamente para eso para la reformación
de las mujeres más afectadas por estos
empleos
pues esa amarilla no eleva esa directora
regional para las américas y el caribe
de naciones unidas le agradecemos por
participar con nosotros y a ustedes los
invitamos a que se queden con nuestra
programación
[Música]